This video is brought to you by Raycon.
The wisecrack Michael here today.
We're going over a topic of concern to both big tech and big Shrek.
Do I have to do to get a little privacy?
Yes, privacy.
The answer district's question is a little weld complicated in our day and age.
Do we uninstalled?
Sorry. I just had to wash my hands before getting in.
Send a strongly worded DM to Mark Zuckerberg become a juggler to foil facial
recognition. Privacy is all over the news. Specifically,
the many ways it's being trampled on.
So exactly how angry should you be if the Chinese or American governments get a
copy of your sick walk, Tik TOK,
we take for granted that this thing called privacy is a universal good that we
should share. Lots of think pieces about,
but what exactly is privacy in the first place?
Where did the idea come from and why does it raise such powerful emotions?
And perhaps most importantly,
why should we care about the state of privacy today?
Let's find out in this wisecrack condition on the philosophy of privacy,
but before we get into it, I want to give a shout out to this week.
Sponsor Ray con rake on earbuds are comfortable wireless earbuds that are the
solution for your podcast or music listening needs.
I prefer these over other earbuds,
mostly because I hate the hard shells that fall out of your ears.
So easily break out of your buds. Also a different size gel tip.
So you will always have a comfortable fit.
They come in a wide variety of colors,
so you can choose the pair that matches your style.
Rake on earbuds started about half the price of other premium wireless earbuds.
And the audio is comparable to the brand. You might know their latest model.
The everyday, each 25 is one of the best yet with six hours of playtime,
seamless, Bluetooth pairing, more base,
and a compact design that gives you a nice noise. Isolating fit.
Ray Connor has a 45 day free return policy.
So why not check it out for yourself?
Click the link in the description or go to Biray con.com/wisecrack.
And you can get 15% off your order. That's by
con.com/wisecrack. Now back to the show, the concept of privacy,
as we know it now likely has its roots in a much more basic concept,
namely property,
the notion that certain things belong to certain people or certain groups and
not to.
Others. [inaudible].
The philosophical discussions around ownership are some of the oldest texts we
have,
and they lay out the separation between an individual and the group to which
that individual belongs. And without that divide,
talking about privacy is kind of pointless.
The most well-known of these treatments comes from Aristotle who posited a
division between what we call the Polis or the public sphere.
And the oil goats are.
That's fair, a healthy protein.
Douglas McDowell points out that oil goes could have one of several different
meanings, depending on the context, in a very literal sense.
It can mean an individual's house,
but it can also mean all of the household goods that Marie Kondo wants you to
trash I E property. And under certain circumstances, family,
which I don't know, do they spark joy? In other words,
the Greek oil goes consisted. All those things,
which could be said to belong to the male head of the household,
the property itself, the commemorative Play-Doh chotchkies Oh,
and also the women, children, and slaves that lived on set property.
These things therefore did not belong to the palace. The public, of course,
many people didn't own land making this not a fun time.
Then very culturally specific distinction between the household and the public
sphere is a big part of the foundational thinking that enables us to say,
for instance, that data about our online behavior is ours,
and that it is therefore a violation of our rights to collect it without our
express consent.
We can see how by fast-forwarding from ancient Greece to colonial America there.
This concept of private ownership was also a big part of the reason why in
between teeth Colin's at the blacksmith's shop,
the founding fathers worked up such a collective head of steam over British
intrusion into their affairs as scholar Daniel J Solove explains revolutionary
Americans had a very specific grievance with the colonial authority at founders
detested, the use of general warrants and writs of assistance.
That is you can have your house searched and seized without any basis in
evidence.
And it was not uncommon for the authorities to grab the personal papers of
dissidence and authors underlying the founders.
Anger was the belief that there is such a thing as personal stuff to begin with.
In other words,
they were willing to endure the pain in the that was musket warfare.
Okay.
In large part to create a division between what the government does and does not
have the right to inspect on demand.
Key American figures were even wary of surveillance by their own government so
much so that they took to writing their post-revolutionary letters in code.
This included folks like George Washington, Thomas Jefferson, yeah.
And Alexander Hamilton, they're ordering this.
Would lead to the third, fourth and fifth amendments.
These prohibited the forced quartering of soldiers in a home without the owner's
consent,
establish the requirements of probable cause for searching and seizing your
stuff and establish the basics of a fair trial. Respectively.
These amendments further refine the concept of privacy with regard to
individuals and the relationship to a liberal democratic government and an
American context.
But it wasn't until 1890 that the modern idea of privacy as a legal concept was
fully articulated that year. Attorney Samuel Warren,
and eventual Supreme court justice,
Louis Brandeis published the right to privacy in the Harvard law review.
It brought immediate and widespread attention to the issue of people poking
their noses and other people's business.
There's two girls behind you.
And publishing their findings and the tabloids.
This was a popular concern in a time when increasing population size and rapid
urbanization brought in many people into closer contact than ever with their
neighbors. And as a result, their domestic dramas in the article,
Warren and Brandeis argued that the common law conception of property
protections ought to cover not just physical property,
but intangible property as well.
Like your sort of Netflix watch history or your idea for the next great workout.
Yeah, sure. Eight minute apps. Yeah. The, uh, exercise video. Yeah. Well,
this is going to blow that right out of the water. Listen to this.
Seven minute apps.
The way they saw it,
the law wasn't keeping up with recent technological developments or the
businesses that profit it off them, specifically newspapers,
the 19th century equivalent of TMZ, as they put it,
gossip is no longer the resource of the idle and of the vicious,
but it's become a trade which has pursued with industry as well as a fronter.
They noted that this new trade profited off of the details of sexual relations,
which can only be procured by intrusion upon the domestic circle.
Broadly speaking,
privacy was then as it is now primarily about protecting your nudes in
more precise terms, legal scholar,
Dorothy Glancy claims that for Warren and Brandeis,
the right to privacy was the right of each individual to protect his or her
psychological integrity by exercising control over information,
which both reflected and effected that individual's personality in this way.
These two sepia tone men expanded the concept of the private yet again,
to include not only the property in an individual's possession and that which is
restricted from government surveillance,
but also what goes on inside one's head and anything that might impact that such
as potentially damaging gossip or in today's day and age,
your Tinder message history more recently in his 1966 study of surveillance
technology law,
professor Alan F Westin pointed out that laws surrounding privacy depend on
context specifically,
whether you're talking about the privacy of your average citizen versus the
privacy of the government in science, privacy, and freedom,
less than explains that different political systems treat privacy differently.
And that norms of privacy are dictated in large part by culture and tradition,
as he put it,
certain privacy patterns are functional necessities for particular kinds of
political regimes.
The modern totalitarian state realized to varying degrees on secrecy for the
regime and full surveillance and disclosure for all other groups.
In other words,
the totalitarianism scene in the Soviet union in Nazi Germany required privacy
for government pair, but the forced lack of privacy for citizens, by contrast,
at least in theory,
the structure of a liberal democracy demands transparency for the government,
coupled with privacy protections for individual citizens.
This statement seems perfectly obvious until you realize that even within
liberal democracies,
we've never actually reached a universal agreement about who ought to have what
kinds of privacy and for what reasons philosophers scholars, legal analyst,
and others with a vested interest have continually argued about whether privacy
is a good or bad thing to begin with in his overview of the history of privacy
and publicness scholar Slav coasts,
the call points out that private relations may also be heavily authoritarian,
violent and even brutal protection of privacy may also have negative effects
under the veil of privacy, abuses of power, including domination, exploitation,
violence, tyranny, and censorship,
as well as unlawful and unethical activities and families, corporations,
and organizations can be kept away from public monitoring and a righteous
sanctions to simplify privacy is great when it means keeping our browsing habits
away from the NSA,
but not so great when it's as a justification for hiding child abuse in the
church, violence in the home. And so on. Even Aristotle,
the very thinker who helped to find the private and public spheres claimed that
we must not regard a citizen as belonging just to himself.
We must rather regard every citizen as a belonging to the state for all his talk
of private ownership. In other words,
Aristotle believed that the private realm extended only so far and that an
individual ultimately existed as part of and to serve a larger hole.
The later challenges to the notion of privacy as an unambiguous good came from
not only utilitarian philosopher and preserved corpse, Jeremy Bentham,
who called privacy,
one of the most mischievously efficient instruments of despotism,
but also feminist thinkers, such as Carol Hanisch who first coined the phrase,
the personal is political Panish and others challenge the idea that there is a
distinction between the public realm of tweeting hot takes and the private realm
of arguing with your partner about what movie to watch next.
They argue that the relationship between husband and wife or mother and children
are inextricably tied up with the politics of a broader society to put it
another way, if a society doesn't value women's agency,
that same idea of leads into the private home.
When a husband refuses to let his wife help decide what to watch on Netflix.
The inverse is also true.
If men refuse to let women make the hard decisions at home,
like whether to rewatch Firefly versus Battlestar Galactica,
they're probably less likely to trust women to vote or hold offices.
According to this strain of thought,
denying the connections between public and private life allowed outright abuse
and oppression to go unchecked, as long as they took place within the home,
beyond the reach of public scrutiny, of course,
this would seemingly make a slam dunk argument for you get no privacy on your
phone, because as lawmakers try to chip away at things like encryption,
they'll inevitably point to someone doing something bad with all that privacy,
as a reason to take away way yours. In spite of these complications,
privacy still has its many defenders in her article.
What privacy is for law professor Julie Cohen argues that privacy is vital for
the development of individual identity or as she calls it critical subjectivity
as she puts it.
Subjectivity is a function of the interplay between emergent selfhood and social
shaping privacy enables situated subjects to navigate within pre-existing
cultural and social matrices,
creating spaces for the play in the work of self making. According to Cohen,
our subjectivity,
that is our sense of individual selfhood as defined both by what's going on
inside our heads and outside of them.
I'll a Warren and Brandeis requires privacy to fully develop in order for us to
form our own opinions, values, et cetera.
We require a buffer zone between what we're thinking and doing and what the
outside world can see. At least some of the time,
this space between us and everything else creates a safe area within which we
can try out new expressions of selfhood and make mistakes that is we can do so
without fear of being mocked by the entire internet for thinking that if a Dora
would really complete our aesthetic or being really,
really into Twilight fanfic here, can we circle back to Western?
And the question of why privacy is so important in the first place,
you'll recall that according to westerns theory,
different kinds of societies need different relationships to privacy in order
exist. The liberal democracy re strive for, for instance,
requires a great deal of privacy for its individual citizens.
Marrying this with Cohen's understanding of the importance of privacy.
We could argue that democracies have to be made up of fully realized individuals
if they are to function correctly. In other words, when we lose our privacy,
we gradually lose the ability to fully develop as humans outside of the public
eye.
And that's bad for the system of government dependent on the will of the people.
And thanks to Warren and Brandeis,
we have some idea about how to maintain that crucial space for individual
development. Funny then that as a society,
we're giving away our privacy like candy corn on Halloween, but seriously,
for a group that's thrown such a massive fit about privacy invasion and data
collection. Over the last few years,
we seem to have very little problem in handing over our deepest secrets to
anybody offering a fun freemium game, and generally mashing that accept button.
Whenever we come across a terms and conditions page.
Fine, you don't want to be part of this, then just sign right here.
No, you didn't read it. This has, we don't ever have to let you out.
And then we can do whatever we want.
Maybe that's not quite fair after all.
We're not just throwing our personal information away for nothing.
When we permit a government or corporation to invade our privacy,
by handing over access to our data,
we generally believe we are getting something of value in return use of a social
network. For instance, as Westin points out,
the need to socialize is a powerful one and setting our privacy as the price of
entry can make it seem cheap by comparison.
He claims that each individual is continually engaged in a personal adjustment
process in which he balances the desire for privacy,
with the desire for disclosure and communication of himself to others in light
of the environmental conditions and social norms set by the society in which he
lives French philosopher and mirror impersonator,
Michel Fuko even went so far as to claim that we are forced to hand over our
privacy rights in order to participate in society,
which makes at least anecdotal sense, even pre-internet,
it's understood that by stepping into the public sphere,
one loses any expectation of privacy as they scream at some poor trader Joe's
employee.
Sure.
Get rid of your Facebook profile with a bit of effort,
but doing so will cause a drastic increase in the number of friends,
birthdays that you miss and in immediate and marked decrease in the number of
parties you get invited to for another example, by now,
we're all mostly aware that rideshare and other apps may track us even when
we're not using their services.
So how many of us actually went out of our way to delete those apps and call an
actual cab every time we want to late night ride home from the bar,
and that's not even touching on how easy it is to manipulate people out of their
personal information, even when they're trying to keep it safe.
As Carnegie Mellon researchers discovered in their review of behavioral analysis
and experiments on people's responses to privacy invasion,
it is startlingly simple to con people out of their data so much.
So they concluded that to be effective.
Privacy policy should protect the naive in certain and the vulnerable.
It should be sufficiently flexible to evolve with the emerging unpredictable
complexities of the information.
So we find ourselves in a bit of a pickle on the one hand,
many of the technologies that make the modern world possible demand our personal
information in exchange for access. And most of us have decided to fork it over.
On the other hand,
privacy is critical for the development of fully formed individuals.
What Julie Cohen calls situated selves,
who in their turn are the starting point for democracy, which most of us,
at least still claim to want, how society will deal with this.
Conundrum is still up in the air.
There's some resistance to our compulsive data collecting scene in the European
union's general data protection regulation,
which requires companies connected to disclose many of their data collection
practices. And Apple's most recent probe privacy publicity push.
Or maybe it's all few titles.
Either way.
The issue of privacy is one we'll need to keep talking about as long as we're
still interested in being people who can cover themselves.
What do you think wisecrack?
What's the state of privacy in the world today and where is the debate headed?
Let us know what you think in the comments. Big,
thanks to our patrons for all your support.
Be sure to hit that subscribe button and as always, thanks for watching.
Later,
[inaudible].